et salut à tous et françois pour la
chaîne explique mme ans encore et
aujourd'hui on va parler d'eux ok ok
c'est vous qui décidez aujourd'hui on va
voir comment on peu floutée un visage
dans une vidéo un an mais bravo c'est
plus voilà c'est plus moi qui décide ce
parti a les seins trop
[Musique]
alors je vous annonce de suite c'est
quand même un cran au dessus de tous
pour la plupart jusqu'à présent mais
c'est loin d'être impossible ou moins
d'être vraiment compliqué donc deux
solutions la première elle va être sur
un os et elle va surtout être utile pour
des plans fixes ou dans lesquels le
visage ne bouge pas et la seconde un
petit peu plus compliqué mais qui offre
énormément de possibilités c'est final
cut pro que j'utilise d'ailleurs pour
monter les vidéos que je vous propose
sur cette chaîne c'est parti on regarde
la première solution sur ios
alors première chose à faire on va
télécharger une application qui
s'appelle vidéo toolbox tient gratuite
mais qui contient des achats in-app
c'est à dire qu'on va devoir payer une
fois l'application téléchargée pour
certaines fonctionnalités et notamment
celle pour foot et qui coûte 3 euros
ouais je sais fait pas la gueule on en
reparlera dans une prochaine vidéo sur
les applications gratuites ou payantes
donc une fois que j'ai téléchargé
l'application je vais l'ouvrir je vais
aller dans masque ici sélectionner les
vidéos up ici
très bien vous voyez que le mas qui
s'applique automatiquement sur une zone
bien précise
je peux le changer ici mettre un flou
plus ou moins élevés et ensuite j'ai
simplement à exporter ici vous voyez
qu'il demande d'acheter la
fonctionnalité on va pouvoir déplacer le
masque pour le sens très bien sur le
visage ici j'irais bien centré ma vidéo
donc y avait pas de souci mais s'il ya
besoin de le déplacer on pourra en cas
de mouvement on peut aussi déplacé le
masque image par image mais sur ios
c'est quand même un petit peu plus
compliqué ce qui m'amène à la deuxième
méthode c'est à dire final cut pro
alors comme son nom l'indiqué final cut
pro c'est un logiciel professionnel donc
un petit peu plus complexe que ce qu'on
a pu voir jusqu'à présent et qui va nous
permettre de déplacer image par image le
flou pour pouvoir suivre le visage
ici vous voyez que j'ai enregistré un
plan où je me déplace comme ça je vais
vous montrer comment on va faire étape
par étape
est ce parti on y va on va commencer par
copier ce plan avec un petit contrôle c
on va ensuite le col et par dessus avec
un compte relever et ensuite pour
définir uniquement la zone que je vais
vouloir floutés je vais sélectionner les
faits masque de forme et je deviens
l'appliquer sur le plan alors vous
pouvez voir que j'ai une petite zone
avec des traits rouges que je vais
pouvoir centrer et redimensionner pour
la mettre uniquement sur le visage
et maintenant avant d'appliquer le chou
on va enregistrer le déplacement de
cette zone pour qu'elle suive un point
précis je vais aller me mettre au tout
début de ma vidéo puis je vais aller
dans la transformation est ici dans
position je vais ajouter une image clé
c'est à dire que final cut va mémorisées
la position de cette zone au tout début
de la vidéo puis sur chaque image du
plan je sélectionne mon poing puis
ensuite avec la flèche du clavier je
vais avancer image par image et je vais
déplacer à chaque fois le masque sur mon
visage
alors par contre ça prend un petit peu
de temps il va falloir s'armer d'un
petit peu de patience
oui je suis très patient je vois pas du
tout ce que vous voulez dire c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que je vais vous
accélérez un petit peu la vidéo voilà
voilà
alors ensuite on va pouvoir se remettre
au début et vérifier que le masque suis
bien deux visages en se déplaçant ici
sur la timeline donc ici c'est bon pas
de problème il ne me reste plus qu'à
ajouter l'effet gaussien sur le plan du
dessus et voilà il reste plus qu'à
lancer la vidéo vous allez voir le flou
pas suivre mon visage
donc voilà j'espère avoir répondu à vos
questions n'hésitez pas à me poser
d'autres dans les commentaires à
demander des tuto sur des sujets
particuliers
moi ça me fait super plaisir de répondre
à vos questions si vous êtes nouveau
sachez qu'il ya une vidéo qui sortent
tous les mardis dont pensez à vous
abonner pour ne rater aucune
et si cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à exploser le petit pouce bleus qui
se trouve juste en dessous et moi je
vous dis à mardi pour une nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]